our planet has been nurturing us for  millennia  it can keep sustaining us but its  resources aren't limitless  we need to act now  to protect the planet for future  generations  and make our societies climate resilient  the european green deal is the eu's  commitment to be the first climate  neutral continent by 2050  it means radically transforming how we  do things  reimagining urban landscapes by  restoring ecosystems and giving space to  nature  [Music]  finding greener ways to move around  [Music]  eating healthily while giving back to  the planet  [Music]  [Music]  we have an opportunity and a  responsibility to set europe and the  world on a more sustainable path  research and innovation hold the  solutions together  let's bring them to life  [Music]  you